mm really they really space to floor
whale right they did a really good job
of spacing the floor
Andre Drummond's started out that play
in the far corner right but you're at
this point if you run another one at him
he's too late to make pass that's that's
a heck of a move yeah gotta get straight
through the third the entire time as
Derrick Rose gets to screen and Drummond
and then get to touch throwing the
shuttle let those out understand their
grosses back hard one way if the
defender losses each spin back the other
way
everything right here's Derrick Rose
doing what Derrick Rose does and that's
get inside get to the spot he wants to
any of siakam right there look at that
behind the back tell me this guy doesn't
still have it Derrick Rose knows that he
can expect results when he and then
he'll set this one up for boost ground
Pistons fight on Fight on Nero's going
off behind the back reverse change
direction and the elevation the hang
time there's quickness Derrick Rose from
distance it's a 10-point game not a
chance
Rick calls time the Pistons have ten
he's probably one of the best finishers
that I ever played for speed his second
foul as well
Derrick Rose gets that deflection Wood
gets the steal but Carlos gets the dunk
to at 44 left corner of God goal of the
trip
but now he is gone in the lane elevating
the hillside too late coming daring
place for contact knows what to do when
he gets it t30 causing a turnover and
then filling the middle lane bomb maker
just came in the game and we're talking
about you to play with energy to get
some energy there in rows the defense
disappeared right under the rim now they
rose over him
Rose had a clear path have had a
12-point lead great recognition by Rose
lip over his head I thought he had
exhausted his options but that is back
nowhere to go poked away
what happened to that basket